it's February 1st 2023 so time for
another monthly update video in which
I'll talk about what we've got coming up
in this short month of February and all
the stuff that you might have missed
from the long month of January all the
things that I'm discussing are linked to
Below in the video description so just
open it up and you can find anything
that you need to check out I always like
to begin by highlighting three big
things so big thing number one it's
actually happening today is we are
beginning the next year of the quarterly
series philosophers in the midst of
History right here in the Milwaukee area
I'll talk more about that in the
February section but we're getting to
somebody who I should have talked about
a long time ago Socrates
big thing number two is that I've
started doing more with YouTube shorts
and I plan to do more of them this
coming month including shorts that are a
little bit more philosophically focused
again I'll talk about that in the
February section big thing number three
is not happening in February but I do
want to put it on your horizon I started
kicking around the idea of restarting
the understanding anger lecture and
discussion series but now in an online
format this is something that I did way
back when we lived in New York in 2015 I
did a number of sessions and I've been
thinking about getting back to it so I
did a uh a uh interesting little session
about that but I'll tell you more about
that as well later on
so what happened in January well there
was one big thing that kind of took me
off track from some of the plans that I
had laid out I got asked very last
minute actually just a week before
classes began if I would take on an
additional academic class for Marquette
University
reprising the service of faith and
promotion of Justice class that I did
last semester for Marquette and it's
focused on anger so you can expect to
see you know significantly more anger
focused content coming out
classes also started at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design I've got two
classes there and intro to Humanities
that meets face to face and a completely
online asynchronous class about
philosophies as ways of life and you've
probably seen some of the videos that
I've been generating for that in in
recent times now what else you know we
did our usual half hour Hegel sessions
uh one for the public one uh just for
patreon supporters did my usual ask me
anything session we finished up uh with
Dan Simmons Hyperion cantos in Worlds of
speculative fiction session 66 which was
a lot of fun that wound up being a very
long video though we did manage to get
together me and my co-host Dan Hayes for
a recording session of wisdom for Life
session 61 about Justice fairness and
anger and you can see the video for that
link to below I also did a few other
things some of them here in the greater
Milwaukee area some of them online so my
wife Andy and I both were part of the
recent stoic hair panel discussion
Roundtable whatever you want to call it
focused on stoicism animal moles and
pets but I was also invited to give a
petrikucha talk which is a bunch of
slides and you you get 20 slides 20
seconds for each slide at the Dare the
possible happy hour at the keckmeric
center for Human Performance I got to
tour the place that was a lot of fun ran
into some old friends there as well and
we finished up the month with a session
uh inaugurating a new series called
philosophy eats at the Women's Club of
Wisconsin it's a meal and we I brought
some Reflections about stoicism and New
Year's resolutions and why we should
break them and switch them to goals that
is a very very local event you could say
and it went quite well I also did
something that I haven't done for quite
a long time a philosophy pop-up this
online thing and I did it in part
because people were really curious about
the class I'm teaching at Marquette
about anger focused you know
specifically on understanding anger and
that got me to thinking that maybe I
should reprise that uh series and do so
now in a very different format that
would allow me to explore way more texts
and thinkers and go a bit deeper than I
had in the past when it was a library
series as I mentioned classes got
started that has been consuming a lot of
my time and thought and bandwidth I also
took on a few new clients for my
tutorials and philosophical
counseling and even academic coaching so
I've been quite busy on that and I've
been doing some writing not as much as
I'd hoped in medium and I've also been
working on this book project that I've
been you know dripping out to patreon
supporters and also in my medium taking
the transcripts from the commentary
videos on epictetuses and critian and
turning them into actual book chapters a
book that I hope to have out sometime I
don't know maybe in the summer or so
maybe in the fall depending on how
things go
I did one interview that uh aired uh
this month with classical wisdom speaks
so they interviewed me about ancient
philosophies and you know
did a bit of other stuff like that
that'll appear down the line uh in
YouTube videos as I mentioned I did some
shorts the shorts that I've been playing
around with are mostly taking footage of
our uh since passed away pets and a few
things from the artwork at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design since people
seem interested in that I also did
several Sadler's stories about a number
of different things and I did a video
about losing my mom as well
um you know her uh date of death happens
at every January and I it kind of sneaks
up on me and think about that I did a
wrap up and review video for 2022 and
thinking about maybe what I'm gonna do
in 2023 I did get one half hour Hegel
video done this month which I released
to my patreon supporters I also you know
released some of the other video goes to
people that I had done last the month
before that
and uh what else I did
um quite a few videos on Blaze Pascal
some core concept videos on some aspects
of his passes that I I hadn't explored
yet and then I started a new speculative
fiction studies series which is almost
done on J.R tolkien's on fairy stories a
really seminal work in understanding
fantasy and even science fiction
literature we did one caption contest
with uh the late great sassy cat trying
to eat my meatball sandwich and a couple
quick takes as well giving some advice
to
people that are interested in philosophy
or academic study more broadly and I
also got a lot of podcast work done you
know finished up with the series on
Aristotle uh then we jumped into
lucretius and did a short series on him
short series on John chrysostom's home
police that was something coming from my
videos from last year when I was
teaching that stuff in the anger class
and then we did plutarchs on controlling
anger also from that class and finished
up the year with podcast episodes on
David Hume and his inquiry concerning
human understanding so uh you know we we
got a lot done in January not as much as
I'd hoped but you know starting that
Marquette class really has consumed a
lot of my available time so you know
maybe we'll get some of it done in
February
so what is coming up in the month of
February well we begin today if you're
here in the greater Milwaukee area and
you want to take a little drive to the
Frank Weinberg library in Mequon I will
be speaking there in the uh philosophers
in the midst of History quarterly Series
this time we are focusing on Socrates
and ancient Athens and we'll be talking
about him and his influence and whether
he has a method or not and his students
and all sorts of other cool matters
um on the that'll happen at 6 PM by the
way on the 4th at noon Central Time
always make sure to check your time zone
we'll have our monthly AMA that has
asked me anything session you want to
get there early and get your questions
in fairly early because we always have
more than we can answer in the 90
minutes that I a lot or even sometimes
we go over over time and we don't get to
everything that same day on the fourth
at 2 pm central time for my patreon
supporters I'll be having a philosophy
chat session that's a little bit more
intimate video conferencing they can ask
me about anything they want and we'll
talk about that
on the 8th we have another similar kind
of session that's at 5 PM Central Time
the Hegel q a and discussion session
which is uh supported by my my patreon
supporters rather underwritten by them
and but you don't have to be one to show
up that is for the general public and uh
it's a zoom session and we we chat about
Hegel German idealism philosophy more
generally
on the 11th uh at uh noon starting at
noon and then you know the second part
of it will start around maybe 1 30 or so
world's a speculative fiction session
67. this time we are looking at
sapkowski's Witcher series we're only
looking at the first four books because
there's you know a lot out there but
that's already quite a lot to go into I
have greatly enjoyed reading them and
I'm getting ready to start shooting them
uh very shooting the video for it very
soon we we begin with a video that
premieres with live chat you can engage
with me directly as I'm talking about uh
sapkowski and The Witcher series and the
World building and philosophical themes
and then we have a more intimate video
conferencing session that you can join
in on as well on
um the 24th we have have the next
philosophy eats that's a you know uh
interesting although you might say not
so easy to to get involved with and you
get a you know join the Women's Club as
far as I know and and it's a great time
talking about different topics and I'll
probably take the stuff that I'm talking
about there and and we'll we'll talk
about it somewhere else down the line so
everyone else can join in and then
finally on the 25th at noon I will be
doing another of the long promised
self-directed studies videos this time
it'll be about Renee Descartes so if
you've ever been wondering you've been
saying I want to get in today card I'm
not quite sure how
I'll help you out with that and so
that's a video premiere with live chat
as well those are all the events going
on this month you know you'll be seeing
other things coming out uh writings and
medium I'm hoping to actually start up a
a newsletter again
um I've been meaning to do that for a
while so I'll probably do that using sub
stack and import you know people who've
been signing up for the newsletter for a
long time I haven't been putting it out
but you know I'll make good on that a
lot of other things going on
um there might be some uh interviews
coming out depending on the schedule for
the podcast people and of course there
is the wisdom for Life radio show which
you can hear every Saturday 5 p.m
Central Time anywhere in the world
because it streams on the internet we
also uh you know put it out in podcast
form and in video form after I get
through with all of that so you know
you'll see all of that stuff coming out
videos I I have some ambitious
scheduling you know in addition to the
events
um and you know the wisdom for Life show
there will also be some shorts coming
out I'll probably still you know do some
stuff about you know Sassy the cat and
her her uh doggy brother and sister uh
Amika and Magnus but uh I'll probably
also be doing some stuff directly about
philosophy about things that I think I
can reasonably bring to your attention
under a minute right this is kind of a
challenge we'll finish up with the
Tolkien we've got one more video to roll
out on on short fairy stories and
um
I've got some uh video stuff to produce
for my classes so some Core Concepts
um diogenes liertes book six of his
lives of the philosophers focused on the
the air uh on aristipus and the sirenaic
school the hedonist school it's got some
videos that'll be rolling out on that
I'm going to be shooting some videos on
locktancius and his uh on the anger of
God which we'll be discussing in just a
few weeks in my classes and then I've
got to produce more videos on seneca's
on anger as well and I do want to get to
something I I didn't get to this month
which is book reviews so I got to do uh
quite a few of those they're starting to
really pile up and I'll also be working
on some stuff that should be coming out
in in March as well including a
Descartes class that you can sign up for
and take with me not for credit it for
for enrichment focused on the
meditations I'll also be getting the
understanding anger series plotted out
and figure out you know where we're
going to go with it and who we're going
to read and what we'll discuss and I'm
going to do some podcast work we've got
more Hume I've already released all the
Hume episodes to my patreon supporters
but I'll be releasing them now to the
general public after that there'll be
some Seneca uh I did you know shoot some
videos on anger earlier last year and
I'll be turning those into podcast
episodes we do have some Aristotle yet
to finish up from book Seven we've
covered almost all of the Nico McCann
ethics but we're going to do that and
then we'll do the diogenes Laertes life
of aristipus and the doctrines of the
serenaic school and we'll see if we can
actually get through all that this this
month or not uh there's a lot going on
there so well that's uh now that I
actually say all that that does sound a
little overly ambitious but we'll see
how much we can get done so I hope you
can join me for some of these online
events if you're in the Milwaukee area
and you know especially tonight you want
uh something to participate in that's
gonna make you think about things you're
interested in Socrates
come on over to the uh Frank Weinberg
library and uh you know if you see me
introduce yourself I'm always happy to
chat with viewers subscribers supporters
fans people who are interested in
philosophy so I hope you have a great
month ahead and uh hopefully everybody
stays healthy as well and I'll see you
somewhere in the interwebs